[Music]
we begin this hour with an update on the
fight against covet 19 here in nevada
thanks for joining us at 4 i'm kirsten
joyce good afternoon to you i'm brian
loftis today governor steve sisilak
saying we have
not seen a significant downward trend in
cases
it was a week ago he announced stay at
home 2.0 urging nevadans to stay at home
for a two-week period 8 news now
reporter kate houston is live right near
the strip
with what potential steps could be taken
next
yes governor siselek compared the spread
of covid 19 in nevada to a wildfire
adding that all options are on the table
to stop the spread of this virus
earlier today governor sisselak joined
members of nevada health response
who say current strategies are not
minimizing the spread of the virus
over the past week the governor and his
team have gathered information and input
from different stakeholders
to see what steps need to be taken
moving forward the governor says
many factors are being considered adding
it's a balancing act between public
health and the economy
you've got to manage everything you've
got to manage the physical health
well-being you've got to manage a mental
health of people there's an economic
situation in terms of people's jobs
and those are things that all part of
the mix that we're going to have to use
to come up with our decision on how to
move forward but this isn't a matter of
waiting or rushing it's a matter of
doing the best we can
nevada health response says it's
important to keep in mind that cases
reported today
were potentially exposed to the virus a
week ago or longer
so the state should start seeing trends
decline as data comes in
during stay at home 2.0 period now
governor sysolak says this will only
work if the community follows the
guidelines
that are in place and i did ask governor
sislek if we should expect
another shutdown he says right now
they're still analyzing the data and
they're waiting
on some input from local counties he
does plan to address this effort in the
near future
reporting live tonight near the las
vegas strip kate houston 8 news now